et puis pour terminer tout à fait ce
journal une réflexion non pas sur la
météo mais sur la condition juive une
réflexion qui nous a été inspirée bien
sûr par l'attentât de la rue copernic
mais aussi par ce livre que vient de
publier
alain finkielkraut et qui s'appelle le
juif imaginaire
philippe harrouard a tracé un portrait
de cet auteur qui s'inscrit donc en
plein dans l'actualité
toute ma vie je me suis affirmé juif je
n'ai pas connu de moments où je voulais
cacher cette identité comme une honte
mais je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
réduit le judaïsme à un personnage
le personnage de l'homme souffrant
meurtri du juste et que ce personnes ce
personnage me fascinait à tel point que
pour moi le judaïsme c'était rien
d'autre que de mid de m'identifier à lui
de m'approprier voracement son image
gratifiante et heureuse et j'ai voulu et
c'est ce que c'est cela que j'appelle le
juge imaginaire l'auteur de ces
nouvelles réflexions sur la question
juive
alain finkielkraut à 31 ans agrégé de
lettres il s'est mis en congé
l'université pour travailler accueillir
deux latéraux portable
le juif imaginaire cache derrière un
titre choc 1 et c'est sincère et
courageux une réponse à la question
juive
judaïsme en tant que peuple ne se range
pas aussi aisément qu'on le croyait dans
les catégories habituelles
il y à l'état d'israël mais le judaïsme
déborde l'état d'israël non ce n'est pas
un état nation et qu'est ce que c'est
j'ai entendu un rabbin lorsque j'étais à
jérusalem un ravin qui est à la fois un
rabbin et âme était un mathématicien me
dire c'est une méta famille c'est à dire
quelque chose comme une famille au delà
de la famille j'accepterai assez bien
cette définition ce que je rejette mois
précisément c'est toutes les puissances
d'oubli tout ce qui pourrait nous amener
à dire le génocide ça n'a pas bien
d'importance la culture qui précédait le
génocide ça n'a pas eu d'importance
la tradition juive dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui elle est monopolisé par
l'orthodoxie ça n'a pas d'importance non
je crois que être juif aujourd'hui c'est
s'efforcer de retrouver contact avec
cela est-ce que vous pensez que votre
livre peut apporter une réponse aux
réflexions qui ont suivi l'attentât de
la rue copernic ce serait peut-être un
peu arrogant de dire puisque mon livre a
été écrit avant et que moi même je ne
sais pas très bien encore ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui je constate
effectivement que l'affirmation juive a
été très forte
ils ont les gens n'ont pas eu peur n'ont
pas cédé et juifs n'ont pas cédé au
chantage de l'assimilation c'est grazay
laisser passer l'orage cette attitude là
qui était celle des juifs pendant
l'affairé dreyfus a complètement disparu
je constate aussi que il y avait eu un
phénomène de solidarité a fait que la
classe politique et avec l'église
la presse que que les juifs non plus
n'ont jamais connu donc si on prend une
perspective historique l'époque pour les
juifs et plus sûr
cela dit il y a effectivement un climat
assez malsain aujourd'hui que je ne suis
pas sûr de bien caractérisé mais par
exemple quand j'ai vu tous ces gens dire
oh là là on en fait trop sur copernic
vraiment
c'est un fait divers et puis tout le
monde s'émeut là j'ai commencé à être
inquiet parce que quand les gens disent
cela ils disent alors si on en fait
tellement c'est que les juifs sont très
puissants et les juifs deviennent
faibles et fragiles
quand beaucoup de gens sont persuadés
qu'ils sont puissants